as it is Valentine's Day I guess now
would be a perfect time to cover a
mythological love story as we did this
time last year with Eros and Psyche but
as with most stories of love with in
greek mythology they often end in
tragedy so today's video on the love
story of artemis and orion may not be
the perfect love story that you were
looking for now some of you may be
thinking that a love story featuring
artemis Stephane sounds a bit odd
because she doesn't have much
interaction with anyone outside of her
clothes followers and the wild life of
her forest most male interaction doesn't
end too well we saw this with the hunter
Acton who was turned into a stag when he
came across the goddess during a hunt
and even with cipriotti 'he's a young
boy who's given the choice of death or
being turned into a girl granted both of
these stories began with them stumbling
across Artemis naked when she took a
bath so perhaps these particular stories
were always destined to end poorly there
are other stories where minor deities
pursued Artemis but these all ended in
rejection and for those who couldn't
take no as an answer the consequences
were a tad more severe when the river
god Alf face had been rejected by
Artemis he decided that he would just
kidnap her anyway when autumn us then
found out of her face his plan she
covered her face in mud when our face
came to collect his new bride he walked
right past Artemis because he didn't
recognize her Artemis was then able to
escape unharmed while still given
herself one of those fancy mud facials
at the same time so what does all of
this have to do with the story of
Artemis and Orion it helps us to paint a
picture because we don't know a whole
lot about Orion in terms of personality
if Artemis rejected the advances of all
other men but then suddenly opens up and
falls in love and we get the idea that I
Ryan was different or special in some
way as for Ryan's backstory he's always
described as an extremely handsome giant
hunter his birth is definitely one of
the weirdest stories in Greek mythology
some accounts simply state that he was a
son of Poseidon and knew
and the wife of King Minos some others
say that he was born from a patch of
earth covered by the hide of a bull
several gods would come across this
particular patch of land and then
urinate on the hide from which then
sprang forward Oh Ryan like a giant man
plant which had just been watered with
divine pee in Orion's early life he fell
in love with the princess Merapi but her
father disapproved of their union so
much that he had a Ryan blinded his
vision would eventually be restored by
the healing rays of Helios the Sun now
finally getting the message that the
king did not want him around
Orion would travel to the island of
Crete where he would eventually meet
antlerless we've now reached the part of
their encounter that I guess we can
consider the crossroads that lead down
the numerous paths and variations of the
story for example there is one story
where Orion meets Artemis and just
immediately forces himself upon her
which needless to say resulted in him
dying quite quickly so this path is
somewhat of a dead end in terms of a
love story this initial encounter in
Crete would have been where a Ryan tried
to impress Artemis and with them both
being hunters it's likely that some kind
of hunt or a shared interest in the wild
and nature would have been where they
first established a connection how long
this connection lasted again varies
depending on which path we take there
was a story where the two fell madly in
love and would then hunt together
continuously trying to outdo each other
and that is until a Ryan made the
mistake of telling Artemis and her
mother that he could slay anything that
came from the earth this only served to
anger Gaia who considered all living
things on earth to be her children and
so she took Orion's boasting as a threat
as you would expect from any mother who
thought her children were in danger Gaia
attempted to protect them she summoned a
giant scorpion which Artemis and Orion
would have to fight together
Orion would sandy be killed during this
battle whether it came from the scorpion
sting or Artemis's accidental arrow the
love story ends here
at the request of Artemis the fallen
hunter would be placed in the sky as the
constellation Orion and the Scorpion as
Scorpio now at this point in time some
of you may be thinking this isn't much
of a love story this just sounds like
the many deaths of Orion and I guess
that in itself is a testament to the
difficulties that Artemis faced in the
love department so let's continue on to
the part of the story where Artemis and
Orion defeat the giant scorpion and go
on to live a long happy and peaceful
life together except that never happened
their relationship was never really left
uninterrupted if Orion wasn't being
killed by Artemis or a giant scorpion
then it would be Artemis his twin
brother Apollo who ensured that the two
would never be together it's not easy to
pinpoint the exact reason for Apollo's
actions but jealousy and they dislike
for giants may have something to do with
it Apollo could have been jealous for
numerous reasons one of them being the
fact that he and his twin sister were
very close
they grew up shunned and isolated by the
rest of the gods and together they
battled and earned the respect and
position they believed they deserved
there's no doubt that they were much
stronger and a force to be reckoned with
when they were together with Orion now
in the picture Apollo would have been
shoved to one side and their time
together would have been limited
arguably making Apollo a weaker he also
may not have liked the fact that Artemis
was willing to give up the vows that she
had taken especially for a giant it's no
secret that Zeus and several other
deities weren't a huge fan of the Giants
and the Paolo share in his father's
disdain is quite possible there is also
of course the idea that Apollo wanted a
romantic relationship of Artemis and
that is why he devised the plan to
remove Orion from the equation one day
Apollo came across a Ryan when he was
bathing in a lake when standing the
giant was submerged to the point where
only his head was visible Apollo
approached Artemis and challenged her to
a competition to determine who was
superior with the bow when she asked her
brother what exactly she would be aiming
at he pointed across the lake at what
seemed like a rock
she accepted her brothers challenge
pulling back her bow firing and hitting
a target Apollo was then overcome with
joy which was quite weird for someone
who had just lost as also a stru closer
to c1 exactly she had hint she realized
that it was a Ryan in the lake it was a
Ryan's head that she had hit and it was
her lover Orion who was now dead
Orion would once again become a
constellation along with his pack of
hunting hounds in one story Apollo
instead pointed to Orion's head which
bobbled in the lake and told Artemis it
was the man responsible for attacking
one of her followers and so Artemis
wanting vengeance did not examine the
situation she just took aim and fired
there is a variant of the story where
Artemis enlists the help of the healer
God Asclepius who brings Orion back from
their dead unfortunately shortly after
he was struck down by Zeus who then
reminds us Lepus that he must be careful
who he brings back from the dead because
it blurs the lines between the dead and
the living the story of Artemis and
Orion is rather odd not in terms of the
story itself but in how many variations
there are which all end with the same
outcome regardless of what story you
read there are none where Artemis and
Orion just live a happy life together
they all end with the death of Orion the
only variables that really change in
this story or how we get to Orion's
death and who is responsible there are
however some meanings or lessons that we
can take from this story one of those
being the importance of remaining
level-headed and making rational
informed decisions we see this with
Orion when he makes the bold claim that
he can kill everything on the earth
which at the time may have sounded like
a way to impress Artemis and her mother
but it also angered Gaia and set in
motion a series of events that would
lead to him being killed this can also
be applied to Artemis when she fired the
arrow that killed Orion
whether it was the pride of being better
than her brother or the need for revenge
she could have approached a situation in
a far more rational and methodical
manner examining her surroundings and
making sure she knew what or in this
case whom she was firing at with that
being said emotions such as love do make
it difficult for us to remain rational
one idea that always stood out to me in
terms of this particular story is the
idea that sometimes some things in life
are just not meant to be and given the
numerous versions of this story that all
end in heartbreak or tragedy I get the
feeling that Artemis and Orion are just
one of those many things I don't know
where this story may rank for you in
terms of Greek mythology's best love
stories because it's kind of a love
story that comes to an end before it
really began so do let me know what your
favorites are in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained wishing you all a
happy a Valentine's Day than Artemis